[Music]
[Applause]
Christmas tree lighting presented by the
five thank you to the Broadway carolers
for getting us in the Christmas mood and
the countdown is on in just a few
minutes we're going to press that big
button and Light Up the Sky and in the
spirit of giving Fox News partner Fox
news media partnered with First
Responders Children's Foundation this is
an important organization they help
provide financial support to children
who have lost a parent in the line of
duty as well as families enduring
significant financial hardship due to
tragic
circumstances Fox news media employees
have generously donated 1,000 gifts to
the benef to benefit the children in the
program and we set up Santa's Workshop
where they turned into elves to wrap the
gifts these gifts and thousands of
others will join the foundation's Toy
Express which handed out 100,000 gifts
in 150 cities across the United States
last year and with us in the crowd are
dozens of First Responders and their
amazing beautiful families who have
received support from the foundation and
on stage next to us is the president and
CEO of this great organization Jillian
crane as well as Christina Moon and her
two children Brianna and Colin they lost
their father last year firefighter
William Moon after he suffered a serious
injury while preparing for a drill
inside his firehouse and the foundation
scholarship recipient Adriana
Hendrickson slack excuse me and her
mother Mara this is Mara Adriana is a
sophomore at New York University her mom
Marsha was a detective with the NYPD and
a first responder on 911 she is now
retired on line of duty disability after
suffering injuries from ground zero and
today is actually Marsha's birthday
happy birthday Mar
and to Jillian crane you are the head of
the First Responders children Foundation
now we were spoking speaking minute ago
you said it started 22 years ago how is
your foundation different than a lot of
the other ones and what got you involved
well we have been here for 22 years and
we are here to help and support children
of First Responders Nationwide so we're
joined here by the FDNY the Port
Authority police department the police
commissioner from the NYPD is here but
really our mission is to support the
children and we do by that I do that by
our scholarship program our line of duty
death bereavement program we step in
with financial help when a when a when a
first responder dies in the line of duty
and then we have a mental health program
for children of First Responders and I
think the thing we have to remember
right now during the holidays is that
when we're with our families First
Responders are out protecting us in
every part of this country and when they
make the ultimate sacrifice it is our
respons responsibility to be here for
those children to be here to support
those families and that is what the
First Responders Children's Foundation
does every single day with help from Fox
and all of you and the whole country
it's an honor to be a part of it and
Adriana tell us a little bit about the
support the program has given to you and
your opportunity to be at NYU I really
feel like I gained a second family um it
was very hard you know growing up and
watching my mom not be able to do a lot
of things that other moms were able to
do because of her injuries and I feel
like especially this past year I you
know got to grow and gain a second
family and you know just relate to other
people and I really thank them for that
what are you studying I'm studying
Global Public Health oh yeah she is and
Marsha how about you how are you doing
today happy birthday thank you very much
I'm doing okay yeah yeah we're glad
you're here and we thank you thank you
yeah well judge all right and I have
here Christina Moon and her children
Brienne 12 and Colin ten uh this is your
first Christmas without your husband he
was a man with a big personality a big
smile he mentored people and he is very
much lost in the fire department by
those members of the fire department how
are you coping this Christmas and how we
get through it you know I think we're
just kind of going to make sure we have
as much time with family as possible and
having organizations like this that step
up and you know provide assistance it's
huge because it just kind of takes a
little worry off and you kind of get to
hug each other a little tighter and a
lot of remember ones and happy memories
you know to be talked about well God
bless you and God bless your family what
are you looking for for
Christmas um a lot of cool stuff all
right I think you get you can get that
and
you family time you got a l and Janice
if you could just join us for we just
have a little bit of time left but you
work with this organization and you can
assure everybody that it does all this
great work yep I'm married to a first
responder and it's good to know that an
organization like this one would be here
for my family and these are quiet Heroes
they don't appreciate the spotlight they
don't like to be in front of the camera
or in front of a microphone but it's
important especially this time of year
to know that these are the men and women
that are brave that go towards danger
when the rest of us are fleeing from it
so thanks to everyone and to the
families thank you for being here today
I've never been feeling so supportive
and safe tonight with all of the first
thank you we thank you all and we hope
you get a lot of cool stuff for
Christmas okay if you at home want to
help this incredible group First
Responders children Foundation you can
donate by
texting strong
224 365 let me say that again strong
224 365 there you go and that I hope you
everybody will do that hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now